hi my name is Jeremy Walker I'm here for
youtube developers live and today is all
about gdes what's a gde you might ask
it's a google developer expert these are
people that helped us with supporting
the api's and spreading knowledge about
the API so they help us answer questions
on stack overflow they talk at events
they help us with hackathons there's
lots of great stuff and we had a gde
summit where a bunch of them from around
the world came out to see us so we
wanted to make sure we pulled them in
and did a couple interviews which is
with each of them so we could see what
they were up to our first one is from
Utah Jeremy McDonald and enjoy the show
next we have our newest addition to the
team jerem he's from Utah so say hello
hi how are you doing so we were talking
before this event a little bit about the
live streaming API which for you that
anybody that doesn't know it life allows
you to tape live events and put them up
on youtube in real time I can you tell
us a little bit about what you're
telling me about the opportunities you
saw being in education I think that that
the live streaming API is is perfect for
really helping extend education into
distance fields whether we're talking
about classrooms whether it's lectures
trying to get more people involved in
educational opportunities the live
streaming API and its ease of use is
really poised to do that well great um
is there anything that surprised you
from when you started from integration
with you yeah I think one of one of the
biggest benefits is the fact that you
only have to send one stream to YouTube
through the API and then the YouTube
takes care of all the transcoding for
multiple devices and multiple formats
most of the time when you see platforms
like this they said they ask you to send
multiple strings but YouTube this
requires the one all right yeah that's
true um anything that you'd request
maybe to improve it probably just
requiring fewer subscribers before
allowing someone to use the API right
now the limit on the number of
subscribers you have is is is too high
according to the most developers who
want to to get their hands on this API
right it was a thousand and we've
dropped it to 100 and keep your your
eyes on that well thanks for joining us
here in Mountain View if you if you're
in utah i'm sure you'll get to see jerem
quite a bit
going about the YouTube API s but feel
free to join us for our next couple
interviews